biggest lies the hair industry has ever
taught us water is not good for our hair
and here's the science that proves it
water does make cuticle scales stand up
hair feels rougher cuticle scales can
break off and it also makes hair
stretchier so wet hair is a lot of the
time more fragile but water isn't
completely bad for hair hair that's too
dry is also more brittle and that means
it isn't stretchy and flexible enough it
can crack more easily it doesn't absorb
shock as well this is a bigger problem
if your hair is kinky or curly black
hair at 65% relative humidity broke a
lot more easily than wet hair using
humans like glycerin would help I've
also talked about how water can reduce
damage when you're combing curly hair
before water is also really good at
resetting damage I think we all know how
water can reset the shape of your hair
some of the things we do can actually
make your cuticle scales buckle and lift
this can get reset by Water Conditioner
doesn't actually flatten this kind of
lifted cuticle it's the water you're
using with your conditioner so I think
it's more accurate to think of water as
not good or bad but it's something where
we want a certain level and it's a tool
that we can use to change hairs
properties